that's the Hollywood part I've seen a
helicopters crash on tarmacs and
different things and I haven't seen one
explode hey my name is Dakota Brody I'm
a 21-year military veteran I served 13
years in the U.S Coast Guard as a search
and rescue helicopter pilot and eight
years in the Army as a uh-60 Blackhawk
helicopter pilot today we're going to
look at helicopter rescue scenes and
movies and judge how real they are
come in boys
for the Coast Guard primarily we Face
offshore and going offshores to affect
most of our rescues however the Coast
Guard does train for vertical surface
rescues which is what you're seeing
right here Cliffside Cliff rescues and
everything else
all right if that is the Hoist hook you
are in what you call a committed
situation every yellow pilot would be
shaken at this point right now knowing
that the Hoist Hook is attached to a
vehicle that could fall off not
happening we're not connecting up to any
vehicle
I'm coming down Harrison you're flying
so a pilot going to the back seat first
of all you know how much stuff you can
knock off you could literally turn off
both of your engines the fact that your
vest and everything could snag and you
could flip things off you've actually
had a person turn with their mvgs
sitting on top of their head and
actually hit one of the engines and
knock an engine offline with that so
yeah it's very possible to actually turn
off something inadvertently just
climbing trying to get to the back of
the cabin out the door
[Music]
if I am outside the helicopter we have a
real bad problem as a pilot I am never
outside
[Music]
we were trying to show like the Hoist
was holding the truck up right the Hoist
that you have on there about 600 pounds
so it's not your primary means of
holding up anything at that point that
it was smoking it was straining so hard
now there is a squid that you could flip
the switch to actually cut and Shear
that hoist cable which is what they were
doing at that point so somehow they
sheared the one cable and The Rock and
the other person was on a different
cable
I don't know what that is I'll say that
our helicopter has one cable that we're
going to operate with once that cable
gets sheared everything's going down
with it it's not going to happen on so
many different levels on this clip this
right here is a zero where are they
tankers on the way Air Force rescue two
three one I don't know why nobody wears
mvgs everybody has mvgs on night vision
goggles on the helicopters nobody wears
them if you have the option of having
them on yeah you're gonna have them on
[Music]
the fuel probe that you just saw that's
not a standard piece of equipment on
helicopters it's just certain
helicopters that are either doing some
long-range rescues most helicopters do
not have that
[Music]
your biggest thing at that point is if
you miss where's that tube that's going
that's flowing fuel if you're going to
cut that thing with the main rotor
you're talking about damage to the main
rotor system you've been a bad spot at
that point
looking right now at a lightning strike
a knock on wood and thank God I've never
had that happen you risk frying a lot of
electronics engine control systems that
are on there you're hoping that your
engines are staying online you would
probably lose a lot of electronic AC and
DC Systems inside the helicopter but you
should be able to keep flying unless you
got hit in like the tail rotor or
something
every year the Coast Guard has to do
what's called dunker training so we get
flipped over in a chair in a pool which
simulates having to ditch your rolled
upside down you have to do multiple
different egresses to show that you have
the proficiency to be able to get out of
a submerged helicopter every single year
and then every six years if unless
they've changed it but every six years
you would go to actual school where you
go through the whole mock-up simulator
of a device going in and rolling over so
this is a part of the business
thank you
he's got these bottle or a heeds bottle
which gives you about two to three
minutes at normal breath in that mode
right there you have about 10 to 15
seconds if they're breathing the way I
think they are but the pure shock of
going in and the water temperature
itself is going to take the breath out
of you but I do like the realistic
aspect of seeing somebody grab that
seeds bottle and put that thing in their
mouth
[Music]
now for everybody that flies we have
emergency jettison handles so the normal
exits are no longer going to get you out
of the door it's too much pressure
that's on that door at that point so
you're literally hitting your emergency
jettison like it's blowing cartridge in
the door pops off it just is lifting up
the actual door hinge pins out of the
way so you can have a create that full
opening at that point anybody's going
for that yeah you're gonna die I give
this one probably about a six
I got the two men you return and pick us
up on my signal
the theatrics on there is amazing they
had no business being that close to a
rig that's exploding so we've done
multiple rescues in the Gulf of Mexico
that's where I was stationed at before
so flying out to rigs rigs typically
have burn-offs happening but there's
always either gases or stuff like that
that's coming off so the rigs all have
more of a Escape type pods and things
for the rig workers to be able to get
out and be able to get off the rigs and
then we would affect the rescue from the
Open Water to try to go into there again
we're no good to anybody and it's so
much risk of that flying debris shrapnel
going through the rotor blade system
you're just now a victim you're not
going to put yourself or the crew in
that situation
five any standard deployment of the
rescue swimmer they're just going down
at that point you just call it a direct
deployment of the rescue swimmer
especially when you're deploying
somebody either to a boat that's
underway you'll have them down you'll
have them just off the water or just
above but to say that you're about to
send somebody through a flame a blow
torch in essence not gonna happen
[Music]
[Applause]
when somebody is on the cable the hook
is actually locked just to prevent any
mishaps where it could inadvertently
come open for somebody to pirouette and
unhook themselves off of the cable at
the same time that's pretty amazing
nobody would be that crazy to even
attempt to put somebody in that
situation the rescue swimmer would come
up and slap everybody in the helicopter
or even putting them down and stuff like
that so absolutely not it's completely
unrealistic that's a zero
Rivers away
when he jumps from the helicopter that's
a free fall deployment of the rescue
swimmer that is reserved for daytime
only so we would only hoisted the rescue
swimmer down at that point not let him
jump from the helicopter they're seeing
like 20-foot swells or something like
that that means the helicopter is
hovering at least 30 to 40 feet you
misjudged that swell that's a four or
five story drop that water turns into a
solid real quick especially if that was
cold temperatures
door
it's a standard rescue basket he's
calling for the basket has it ready for
pickup sign that's exactly what you
would hear because we're standing by
keeping our light in the direction of
the swimmer kind of making sure we
always have sight on them and as they're
getting ready you're going to try to
place the device really within about
five to ten feet of them once they're
calling for it so very very real
that Bingo fuel that's a real term it
just means like if you leave now you
will land with a fuel Reserve when you
get back at your station anything that's
less than there you can be at risk of
either not making it to your destination
the airport or flaming out it's always a
race against how much fuel you have
[Music]
when you're seeing the wins that rotor
wash it's beating down on you it's a
mini hurricane underneath it there's no
communicating with the swimmer in the
water at that wait in time all hand arm
signals that would be insane to think
that you're going to hear a person a
swimmer in the water underneath a
spinning helicopter not going to happen
on there
the camera
[Music]
the waves out there that's in like the
Arctic kind of where I believe that
scene was taking place 20 30 foot seas
and even having rogue waves can happen
but you try to be above that the
explosion that's the Hollywood part I've
seen a helicopters crash on tarmacs and
different things and I haven't seen one
explode even in the Army I saw one take
a sa-7 and hit the engine out that was
the only one I saw that was on fire I
would give it a seven
[Music]
so far right now you're seeing pretty
much a legitimate helicopter rescue it's
daytime you can Free Fall the swimmer in
daytime their altitude was good where
the swimmer could safely go out the
swimmer's going to have their goggles
everything down they're not going to
Free Fall with their gear up they go in
the water they're going to lose all
their gear so they're going down they're
going to cover their mask and everything
has it going in
the device going down and being placed
about five feet from them in the water
that's just textbook Coast Guard rescue
swimmer operations on there
[Music]
when you have Baywatch that's really the
LA County's fire department their AKA
Baywatch here in the Los Angeles area we
hoist with them routinely the rescue
swimmer could easily just bring them
over to the vessel the fire department
and they're trained paramedics as well
primarily you're going to try to put
people in with the least risky rescue
method which would be to put them on the
boat unless they had sustained something
else that they needed immediate
transport they'll bring them to the
helicopter and transport them to the
nearest hospital but the rescue in
itself that's pretty textbook for what
you could see if you're going to Free
Fall the rescue swimmer yes it's a nine
just because of how the rescue swimmer
had his goggles and stuff on top of his
head
I love the Precision flying on that this
is the mh-68 or aw109 the Stingrays
really what you'll call for hitron which
is our helicopters tactics interdiction
it's a specialized unit that we have
that primarily their focus is
interdicting either drug smugglers or
anything else like that in international
waters mostly dealing with drug
smuggling what you'll call it go fast
they'll typically outrun a boat their
normal cruise is somewhere around like
the 120 to 130 130 knots if you're
really got like a good tailwind and
stuff like that
watch out he got a weapon on board
I've never been at hitron I did fly uh
Airborne use of force with the Coast
Guard a lot of times what you're trying
to do is we're going to try to stay
outside of what they have on the
onboarder there and make sure we can at
least maximize the use of our weapon
systems
it went for the kill shots right there
so normally they're going to probably
put some stitches in the water they say
stitches in the water because you see it
it looks like stitches from the machine
gun being going out that's kind of just
to escalate the level of the use of
force at that point before they try to
shoot the engines out and really are
more so trying to just disable the
vessel that's primarily what they're
doing yeah is disabling The Vessel so I
give them about a seven
at any point in time you're committed
you have something that's attached to
something that can pull you down that's
just the worst situation for a
helicopter right so you're just at the
mercy of being on that pivot point and
just completely helpless
adorable
wet slippery hand conditions trying to
hold on to a ladder with adrenaline and
the amount of rotor wash it's a mini
hurricane down there so you're holding
on with quite a bit of grip so I'm
pretty sure you're almost probably bear
hugging the ladder at any point just to
try to maintain your grip we're gonna
stop
they were actually doing well talking as
a crew for saying get rid of it that's a
tough call it sounds easy to watch the
movie and say that but that is a really
hard call to say sheer even when we're
getting ready to start any hoists and
rescues like hey if this happens it'll
say sheer three times
safety Powers them or the flight Mech
you race for that sheer button it was an
eight for how Dynamic that environment
would be
the stretcher we call it a litter
anytime we're going to use a litter
we're going to use a trail line to help
stabilize because that flat plane
surface that's underneath with all the
rotor wash that's down below will really
have a good propensity to have somebody
start spinning really quick
foreign
I'm not sure what was causing the pilot
to struggle so much he's got the whole
ship to look at as far as in reference
power really wasn't an issue it almost
looked like they were making the Hoist
cable feel like it was somehow taking
power away from the engines I don't know
having a fouled cable or watching the
cable actually bird cage that part is
real that can't happen so it could go in
there and not be you can't let out some
more cable at that point
here
I don't understand why the pilot was
struggling so bad I'm not sure at this
point what's got a hold of him is some
good bait that's clearly under there for
whatever is eating on them so there's no
need to take the whole helicopter down
sheer sheer sheer a lot to preserve the
lives of the rest of the crew there's
nothing else you could do this is more
of a three
please don't shoot the flare at the
helicopter we see the flare in the
distance trust us the flare gets all the
wrap it'll start eating through it's
like a phosphorus material so you're
shooting like hot phosphorus at the
thing that's trying to rescue you you're
trying to take us down with you at that
point in time the flare is meant to be
seen not to be caught we just want to
see the flare go up and then find the
point of origin so we could come in and
affect the rescues
a lot of times we're going out
it's more likely just one helicopter not
saying you can't have two if it's a long
shore rescue as well there's a fixed
Wing asset overhead that will probably
go out and do really good radar sweeps
inside of the area and try to help us
and they'll also be able to drop and
deliver any type of rescue materials
certain helicopters do have radar
systems so we're trying to either see a
blip on the radar or we're trying to map
the shoreline when we're out there in
really poor weather conditions
[Music]
the helicopters have a few different
lights so each pilot have their own
Searchlight and then a lot of times
you'll operate with What's called the
night Sun so it's just a really powerful
Searchlight towards the middle of the
back of the cabin this right here is
probably a 9.5 favorite one that I've
seen so far is is probably the guardian
it captures the essence they are
consummate professionals and they
understand that at any point they could
be left there hey if you like this type
of video click above to see some more